[Musique]
c'est un bâtiment intrigant un îlot de
verre et de béton dont on ne devine pas
tout de suite la fonction quelques
indices s'accroche à la façade
ce sont les armoiries de besançon depuis
le moyen âge
il a ceci de particulier ici qu'il est
posé sur une roue un kir associés donc
la ville de besançon et l'horlogerie le
sydor société immobilière pour le
développement de l'horlogerie est un
immeuble construit en 1947 48 pour
regrouper des fabricants leap qui se
trouve un peu à l'étroit dans la rue des
chalets adjacentes
mais aussi les pierres de montres cheval
frères ou les ressorts auger c'est un
bâtiment qui est conçu pour l'horlogerie
on a besoin de lumière mais pas trop de
lumière il faut on a un travail ceux des
petites pièces en cuivre qui brille à la
lumière les architectes venus de
saint-etienne lucien seignol et alfred
ferraz dessine un bâtiment en croix pour
multiplier les surfaces vitrées
le projet originel est rabaissée de cinq
à quatre étages mais il en impose
suffisamment pour rivaliser d'éclat avec
les concurrents suisses tous les deux
donc en plusieurs autres monuments qui
sont classées au patrimoine du xxème
siècle ce sont des architectes d'avant
garde
l'intérieur est aussi impressionnant un
escalier à double révolution entoure un
monte charge des huées les activités
horlogères quitte le 6 d'or en 1982 le
bâtiment passe dans les mains de
marchands de biens se dégrade et même
squat et au terme d'un imbroglio
juridique seule une partie réaménagé en
bureau cabinets médicaux et logement
lucette et gabriel cyr ont investi leur
appartement en 1992 il est tout
cinquième étage sous les toits à
l'époque on y entrepose les cuirs et
bref les montres gabriel cyr s'est
passionné pour l'histoire du lieu ses
productions et ses heures de gloire
enfin les résultats du concours de
besançon sont d'autant plus remarquables
qu'elles ont été obtenues à partir
d'éléments fabriqués en grande série
si l'on doit retenir quelque chose de
l'immeuble
sydor seiler 27 c'est un mouvement
électro mécaniques donc l'argument c'est
de dire vous avez une montre que vous
pouvez déposer dans un tiroir
vous revenez la chercher ici mois après
sans la voir remonter
elle fonctionnera toujours tout le monde
peut coûter excessivement cher plusieurs
fois le prix d'une petite voiture
gabriel cyr a tenté de protéger et faire
classer le sydor en vain reste le
plaisir d'habiter un monument de
l'horlogerie byzantine
comme dans tous les lieux industriels il
y a une âme à celui qui voit celle qui
peut la rencontrer
on peut s'imaginer en ouvriers ou
pourquoi pas en frais de l'ip descendant
le les escaliers en redescendant
justement on trouva les tâches de
valérie arnaud un espace encore dans son
jus à l'origine donc c'était cette
surface là sur lequel les ouvriers
travailler avec des machines outils un
espace immense à réinventer valérie
arnaud elle s'est fabriqué en atelier
pour restaurer des oeuvres d'art
je voulais quelque chose qui soit à la
fois lumineux et pas non plus plein
soleil
je voulais une belle surface pour
pouvoir avoir quelquefois des tableaux
d'une dimension hors du commun et la
restauratrice a le sentiment elle aussi
de s'inscrire dans une longue histoire
je poursuis cette tradition est bien ça
ça me touche énormément en fait même si
c'est pas le même domaine c'est de
l'artisanat et c'est un métier de bien
faire soixante dix ans après sa
construction le sydor vieillissant mais
lumineux exerce toujours son pouvoir
d'attraction
[Musique]